now that we know about rectangular and
polar forms of complex numbers
one of the most important things to do
is to work out in what circumstances you
should use
each particular form each one has its
own unique strengths and advantages and
this particular question
tries to sort of bring out some of the
situations where you might want to use
polar form or where you might want to
use rectangular form depending on what
kinds of things you're doing
with these complex numbers so let's have
a look at the question try and unpack
what's going on
they introduced to you a couple of
complex numbers on
the plane you've got z1 over here 1 plus
5i
and z2 3 plus 2i then they say
let z this particular number which we're
going to focus on throughout this
question
let it be the quotient of z1 and z2 what
happens when you divide
this complex number by this one and then
there's a series of questions that
follow from this and you can see
parts a b and c as is often the case are
really all leading in one direction
so part c is kind of the real question
as it were
and parts a and b are what us teachers
like to call scaffolds they're things
that are going to
get us like stepping stones all the way
towards c which is the final result
so let's have a go at trying to answer
the question in the way that they've
framed it
and then we're also going to compare it
with well what if we just got given the
question um without any
guidance on a specific method how would
we solve it and can we confirm that we
get the same answer
either way so first thing says find the
modulus of z
that's that's this quotient here without
finding z
okay so you can see um on both part a
and b what they're trying to say is
don't just divide through a uh sorry z1
divided by z2
see if you can work out the modulus and
in a second the argument without
actually evaluating the number itself so
how do we go about this
what we need to remember and we
developed this from polar form right
is that when you are taking the modulus
of something which
is a quotient what we do when we
multiply complex numbers is we multiply
the moduli
here i'm not multiplying i'm dividing so
we get to take the inverse of that
instead of multiplying the moduli we
will divide the moduli
and you can see that in very simple
algebraic terms because
z is defined as z1 on
z2 therefore the modulus to z is just
the modulus
of that fraction and one of the things
about the absolute value
is that the absolute value of a quotient
is the quotient
of the absolute value so i can actually
just do these two separately
like so
so how do i work out what each of these
are remember
we can think about this geometrically we
get this from pythagoras theorem
the modulus is the distance from the
origin to
said complex number so really what we're
using is uh you know the right angle
triangle
with our rectangular bits in there in
this case one and five and then
three and two and when they're just
we're going to feed them into pythagoras
theorem so
just to remind you right the absolute
value of
a plus i b for some arbitrary complex
number
is going to be the square root of a
squared plus
b squared right so the modulus is like c
it's the hypotenuse here so let's go
ahead and do that with these particular
z1 and z2 on the numerator i'm going to
have
the square root of uh what are my
coefficients here what my a and b
they are by the looks of it i'll just
highlight it up the top here they're
going to be 1 and 5.
so i get 1 squared plus 5 squared
underneath the square root
and then when i go on to the denominator
again i'm going to get a square root
this time you can see up the top there
my a and b will be 3
and 2 so i get 3 squared plus 2 squared
okay let's start to simplify this out on
the numerator it looks like i'm getting
the square root of 1 plus 25 so that's
going to be the square root of 26
and in the denominator i'm getting the
square root of 9 plus 4
which is 13. so square root of 13
coincidentally not coincidentally it's
designed this way square 26
divided by the square root of 13 that's
a factor so i just get the square root
of 2
at the bottom in case you were uncertain
about that uh just like we were seeing
with the absolute value
the quotient of square roots is the
square root of
the quotient so that's kind of a handy
thing to simplify
all right so i'm done that's part a i
have found the modulus
without finding where the actual number
is and i've gotten that from
i should write part a i've gotten that
from the fact that when you
divide two complex numbers the modulus
you just divide the moduli
okay great part b find
this thing here and hence find r z
without finding z all right so
we need to take a bit of a run up to
understand what this question is asking
and why i mean we could just evaluate it
as it is but i think it's very important
to
know why have they handed us this
expression here like where
where did this come from okay so what we
want to think about is
just like in part a if you want to find
the modulus
of dividing two complex numbers then we
divide the moduli
well how do we do the same thing for the
arguments well when you multiply complex
numbers
you add the arguments there's that very
handy alliteration that we've
seen before since we are not multiplying
we are dividing
instead of adding the arguments we're
going to subtract the arguments and
that's why you can see in here there's
this
minus sign right so let's try and unpack
what's going on and put the working that
will explain what's happening right
with my complex numbers z1 and z2 it's
important to know that they are both
in the first quadrant as a consequence
of being in the first quadrant
we can actually use tan inverse to find
out the arguments of each of those two
complex numbers
directly because they're in the first
quadrant so we don't need to worry about
oh
in the second and third quadrants um you
know 10 inverse can't tell the
difference between
the second quadrant and the fourth
quadrant it also can't tell the
difference in the first quadrant and the
third quadrant because you end up with
the same
sign for tan but because i already know
from the outset that z1 and z2
are both in the first quadrant and i'm
going to write this i can therefore use
tan inverse so i'm going to say
since z1 and z2
are in the first quadrant
i can state what their arguments are
directly from tan inverse i can say arg
of z1 is going to be equal to
tan inverse of and from looking at this
number
it's going to be the y on the x this is
the opposite and this is the adjacent
if you want to think about you know uh
if i had one plus 5i where would that
look like somewhere like that
so this is 1 plus 5 i so when i put in
my 5 there that's the
opposite side to the angle that i'm
interested in and
here is my 1 over here in my right angle
triangle so you can see
if this is my theta then tan inverse
of this angle will be 5 over 1 opposite
on adjacent
okay so let's come back over here so
this is 5
over 1 which of course i'll simplify in
a second and
arg of z 2 is going to be
10 inverse of what was it it's going to
be 2 over 3. again it's the y
on the x so i'm going to write that like
so
so because i've got this fact that when
i divide
complex numbers i am subtracting the
arguments i can say
that the argument of just plain old zed
is going to be
the first argument take away the second
argument like so so hopefully you're
starting to see okay well
this here i can substitute these pieces
and it's starting to
look a whole lot like what was presented
to me in the question so
if i do this substitution this of course
was 10
inverse of 5. this was 10
inverse of 2 3. this is arg z
but they're not asking us to evaluate
this i don't have
you know some exact values for five and
two-thirds that doesn't sit in a nice
neat triangle that i know so what i'm
going to do is as the question suggests
i'm going to take 10 of both
sides so i'm going to go tan of arg z
and that means i'm going to have 10 of
the entire thing on the right hand side
so
i'm just going to whoopsies here i'm
just going to grab that
and i'm taking the entire thing on the
right hand side now
it is worth noting you have to be quite
cautious with taking
uh trigonometric functions of inverse
trigonometric functions and
vice versa and that's because
particularly with sine and cosine sine
inverse and cos inverse
they both have we have to do funky
things with them to make sure that the
inverse functions
are actually functions that's something
we deal with under that topic separately
with 10 and tim 10 inverse we're fairly
lucky in that
the domain restrictions are a little bit
different so when i'm going to evaluate
shortly
tan of 10 inverse of 5 we are just going
to get
5. so that's something that we can do in
this question because of the nature of
10 and 10 inverse but do be careful
trig and inverse trig mixing together is
a common place where people simplify
without understanding the nuances anyway
we can address that
later on now as the question is said
we've just taken this run up to get to
what the question is asking us find tan
of tan inverse etc
and hence find r z so in order to do
this in order to unpack what's going on
we need to recognize that this here is
really a compound angular formula
maybe it doesn't look like that remember
tan inverse of five is an angle
it's the argument to z1 and tan inverse
of
two-thirds is also an angle it's the
argument to z2
so really this is actually i could write
this as
i'll do it in purple tan of a
minus b where a and b capital a and
capital b
are the angles involved